as you know Oprah's here you've seen her
for the past couple of minutes she's
here though to exclusively exclusively
reveal her new book club selection we're
gonna talk to her about that in just a
minute but first
Oprah's delivered her words of wisdom to
students around the country this May she
gave guidance to Colorado College's
graduating class of 2019 she told them
they can transform the world every day
by their actions
life is about decisions and the decision
is that you will use your life in
service you will be in service to life
and you will speak up you will show up
you will stand up you will sit in you
will volunteer you will vote you will
shout out you will help you will Linda
Han you will offer your talent and your
kindness however you can and you will
radically transform whatever moment
you're in which leads to bigger moments
did you write that in the car on one of
your mantras that I like you said
everything is always working out for me
what does that mean well I try to teach
that to all my girls because I feel in
South Africa grows in South Africa who
end up at my home for Thanksgiving i
everything is always working out for me
means no matter what crisis you're going
through at any moment that thing's gonna
pass don't we know that now yes now that
you're older because when you're younger
you think every time that it's so
daunting but everything's always working
out for me I use that as a mantra even
when I'm in something that feels like
it's challenging everything's always
gonna work out you also gave the kids
some advice that they don't typically
get these days kids are looking for
meaning in their work for purpose but
you say no keep a job keep a job yes I
had one of those girls who was like I
had it one of my name one of my girls
why did you come to my house and talk to
my daughter I go through my schools I
got a great job she's working at a bank
he's doing you know great stem girl and
she's like I don't know if I want the
promotion because my feeling fulfilled
enough girl keep that job
your mind you get fulfilled later we saw
a clip of you earlier donating to
Morehouse College the scholarship fund
you played it was it was how many years
ago that you initially don't it was like
I you know I went there for an unveiling
of a photograph that they have been
trying to get there for this unveiling
for years because I've given money so
many years ago I I think I heard that
day 30 years ago I didn't realize it had
been night long and so I went there not
intending to give any money I was just
going to be honored they were unveiling
your portrait yeah so that was totally
spontaneous it was totally spontaneous
because the the Oprah scholars who I've
you know helped give scholarships to
over the years these young men gave such
an incredible presentation at lunch you
know what moved me is these guys all had
gone out and gotten suits for themselves
you know because students usually don't
have so they were all dressed up in
their suits and they brought roses and
they brought roses and because they did
that I was so impressed with that and
when I heard that I had only given 12
million dollars I thought only but you
decide to give 13 that's such an odd
number why did you dirty makes 25 so you
just picked that that's why I did it
so she likes round numbers but this is
the thing about Oprah Joseph who's my
assistant at the magazine said did you
know forgave 13 million ago she did I
just talked to her she made no mention
of it whatsoever no name that's really
the that's how I went to lunch and they
I was so impressed she said yeah I went
to lunch and I was listening to their
stories and I thought well this could
help people gonna be trying to impress
[Laughter]
those guys in the suits they probably
walking off that campus with some
student debt I mean college is beautiful
these days is kinds of services the
campuses are gorgeous but it seems like
affordability is like an afterthought
tuition keeps going up yes and and we
need to do something about that we need
to do something about that this country
yes